[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
NBA tip-off hotline presented by
DraftKings sports book and official
sports betting partner of the NBA used
the promo code Patrick make any five
dollar bet this week get 200 if your
team wins I was reading Chris mannix's
latest column one of the great writers
with the NBA and uh senior writer with
sports illustrator Mannix joins us on
the program before I get to the NBA
White Men Can't Jump
good great
oh great
yeah
and hopefully not to be remade uh in
some haphazard way over the next few
years I think it's being remade isn't
Jack Harlow the rapper who else is in
that movie Marv do you know
efforting okay yeah it's been I had I
had I had this feeling though Dan when
they remade Point Break years ago which
wasn't actually terrible the Remake it
wasn't awful it could have been a lot
worse it just didn't make any sense I
mean if you had given me like the option
of going to a theater to see Keanu
Reeves Gary Busey of the Old Point Break
or a new Point Break that I've never
seen I would have chosen the Old Point
Break in a theater I feel the same way
about a White Men Can't Jump remake
right Marvin's working yes yeah we have
multiple confirmations white man can't
jump is in production Blake Griffin's
one of The Producers uh the musician
Jack Harlow is set to make his acting
debut in it and there's that's about all
the details right now that's not gonna
go well wait wait well who is who's
going to be his counterpart in White Men
Can't Jump
it says a gentleman by the name of sin
qua walls
well maybe he's got more game than
Wesley Snipes did
all right man
um the Lakers situation I know that you
said you got to make this move right now
but and and if you're the Pacers if you
make this move they're in the victor one
by Yama sweepstakes so they'd like to
unload whatever Talent they have why
hasn't this deal been done
because it's a steep price for the
Lakers to pay for two players that may
not guarantee them anything more than a
playoff appearance
um you know the teams that are talking
to the Lakers they want at least one or
both of those 2027 or 2029 draft picks
they want them unprotected uh because
the expectation is the Lakers who look
even though they won the championship in
2020 in the last I think nine years
they've only what been to the playoffs
two or three times so there's a pretty
good chance that when we get to 2027 or
2029 that team is a mess but the Lakers
you know they made their deal Dan when
they extended LeBron James they
committed to doing whatever it took to
win a championship over the next two or
three years so while I agree that Miles
Turner and Buddy hield doesn't guarantee
anything it at the very least makes you
better right now and at the very least
gets you into the playoffs and once
you're in the playoffs maybe you can
lean on LeBron to do something special
but you ask what the hold up is it's the
Steep price the Pacers are have been
asking uh in the past Lakers to pay
yeah but I I start to wonder if the
Lakers front office is saying hey LeBron
you got yourself into this you get
yourself out of this we don't want to
mortgage our future when you're not
going to be here do you think there's
any validity to them well there was
validity to that before LeBron signed
the extension right like if LeBron had
not signed that extension
we wouldn't be having this conversation
the Lakers would be completely justified
in not mortgaging the future for a guy
that may only be there for the remainder
of the season but LeBron extended for
two more years he's going to be a Laker
God knows how long his career is going
to last but at least through the these
remaining quality years of his career so
the Lakers when LeBron did that look
this isn't conjecture Rob palenka came
out and said last month we're going to
do whatever it takes including those
picks to make the Lakers better well the
deal that's available right now the best
deal available involves Indiana and
involves Miles Turner and Buddy hield
and it feels like Dan that this is going
to get done eventually like I keep
hearing the Lakers they're going to wait
till Thanksgiving before opening up
things for Russell Westbrook that's like
I I don't even know what the comparison
it's like a wait till Thanksgiving
before I decide which swimsuit model I'm
going to go out with like it it the the
Market's open for Russell Westbrook
right now he's available right now
there's just is no team out there other
than maybe Indiana or perhaps Utah who
would offer up a Mike Conley centered
package maybe Jordan Clarkson uh to get
a deal done so the Lakers they've got to
do it or else this season it very easily
could unravel quickly
and then meanwhile you have the Clippers
who nobody talks about
now I know that they're up there with
the being one of the co-favorites or you
know one of the three favorites right
now but uh what do you what do you see
with the Clippers so far you know I'm
gonna Reserve judgment on the Clippers
until around Christmas time because
the Kawaii
this early because of the knee is
problematic he's 15 months removed from
surgery like that's well past the normal
time it takes for players to recover
from a procedure like that there's a
chance and I've talked to people within
the Clippers that they're just being
overly cautious abundantly cautious with
Kawhi over these first couple of months
as he re-ramps up but I think around
Christmas time we'll know what we have
with the Clippers not just if Kauai is
able to play 75 80 of the games and
still be the old Kawhi letter but also
is their point guard position
Championship level with Reggie Jackson
and John Wall some of the depth they
have on that roster we I just need more
information about the Clippers before I
can judge if they are the the finals
Contender we believe they're going to be
I know it's a small sample size the Nets
are off to their worst starts since
2015. they won 21 games that year they
fired Lionel Hollins as the head coach
I'm watching I mean Kyrie had some
unbelievable plays last night crazy
crazy unbelievable place
but it still comes back to Ben Simmons
it's you you can't watch the Nets
without just watching Ben Simmons what
he does and what he doesn't do and I'm
wondering
at what point
is this
can you make him a starter can you bring
him off the bench it like give me the
I guess he's a liability here Chris I
guess there's no other way to put it
he's not a asset right now that's for
sure uh watching that game last night he
had a couple of good moments uh you know
he defended well at times on Luka doncic
um he finished a couple of shots around
the rim but then you can see it in his
eyes he's not comfortable at a position
where he's gonna have to shoot like you
can see it like when the camera pans to
him he has that kind of deer in the
headlights look when it's it's an
opportunity for him to either take a
shot or collect a ball near the rim
whether it's he's afraid he's gonna miss
he had that air ball layup which was not
good or if he's afraid to go to the free
throw line where he's still not
comfortable uh shooting free throws I
don't think the Nets have much of a
choice but to keep rolling him out there
30 35 minutes per game and showing
confidence in him because that's what
what this is all about the skills in Ben
Simmons are still there all the things
that made him great in Philadelphia are
still there his confidence right now
though looks like it's just a wreck so
if you're the Nets the only way to
rebuild that confidence is to play them
and and to keep pushing them out there
and see if time resolves some of the
mental issues he's been dealing with
talking to Chris Mannix the Sports
Illustrated senior writer
this Klay Thompson situation
I don't know if it's a big deal little
deal no deal but minutes are reduced
he's struggling he's not the player he
once was I don't know if he ever will be
but you know what happened with Devin
Booker uh what do you make of that is
that just a one-off that hey bad night
and uh you know he'll he'll be okay down
the road
you know we'll see it was certainly the
level of frustration we haven't seen
from Klay Thompson in the past
um when I talked to Scouts about clay
before the season
um I I talked to people that watched or
were involved with in the Dallas series
and the one thing that kept coming back
consistently was look clay still making
shots like you leave him open he's going
to beat you every single time but he's
not as quick off the dribble as he was
before the injuries he's not the
defender he was before the injuries and
we're now
a good distance away from his return to
basketball and he's still not that guy
now will that come back over time I
don't know but Klay Thompson right now
in his 30s it's unlikely he's ever going
to get back to being the player that he
once was and I guess it all depends on
how clay deals with that like is he
willing to accept some limitations in
his game because those limitations are
there right now it doesn't mean he still
can't be a top player he helped that
team win a championship they didn't win
a championship without him last season
but I I don't believe will ever see the
Klay Thompson we saw before the two
injuries because his body you know at
least the people that watch him tell me
his body just isn't letting him do the
things he was used to doing
how are my Cavaliers doing
well and Ricky Rubio comes back they'll
take off but right now they're they're
playing they're great Dan like they look
they're three in one right with Garland
still dealing with the eye injury the
Mitchell trade looks like it works
they're still trying to figure out who
goes in that Lowry marketing old spot
whether it's isaacoro D Wade they're
throwing a bunch of guys in there but
the Mitchell deal worked exactly as they
wanted to work they needed another
playmaker they needed a perimeter score
and that's exactly what Donovan's been
his average at almost 30 points a game
and he's playing defense at a level we
didn't see last year uh in Utah I mean I
still I can't buy the cabs as a
contender this year because there's too
many young pieces there like I don't
know what Evan Mobley is going to do in
the playoffs Mitchell has had playoff
success but not at the highest level
Garland same thing don't know what he's
gonna do in the playoffs but of all the
young teams in the league that are kind
of on the brink that's the team I'd want
to be the most because they've got
enormous upside over the next couple of
years and if Mitchell is happy there and
wants to stay around and wants to extend
his contract that's a team that that can
be a contender for multiple
championships down the line we're going
to have that moment this year it feels
like with the Victor wumbayama and these
teams that you know managerial tanking I
guess uh we're gonna see this maybe with
the Pacers maybe we see it with him I
thought Utah was trying to do that but
uh how do you discourage tanking if
you're the commissioner
I mean you what was that what did the
owner and Major League do you trade away
all your good players like that's that's
kind of what you do
um I look I don't I'm sure Danny Ainge
isn't sitting in his office in Salt Lake
City thinking he's going to be a buyer
now that the Jazz started three and one
like they have like the 19 win Sixers
started 3-0 on their season like the
things regress to the mean and some of
the things the Jazz are doing are
probably not sustainable at the moment
but you are going to see these teams
that believe they have a chance to
finish in that bottom three trade away
guys or in in the case of guys they want
bench them for the rest of the season
the NBA hates it but there's nothing
that they're going to do about it the
question it's not new right I mean
Oklahoma City sat Al Horford second half
of the season a couple of years ago
they've killed us Alexander seemingly
every season that he's been there the
question is not will teams do it it's
how early our team's gonna do it will we
see a team or team teams with the
audacity to shut down players before the
All-Star break because they want to
stumble and lose enough games to get in
that bottom three that that's what I'm
most interested in seeing you're gonna
see some guys traded away and you guys
see some guys shut down at levels that
you've probably never seen before
because not to make this about Victor
but he is
outside of LeBron and maybe even more
than LeBron the best Prospect we've ever
seen he is transformational more than
numbers maybe maybe because LeBron
coming into the pros was physically
remarkable right like you never saw a
high school player that looked like that
but he had some flaws in his game right
he wasn't a perimeter shooter at that
point and he had a ways to go to become
a complete score one bayama's out there
you know shooting a good percentage from
three seven foot four he's he does
everything a little bit of everything
right now at a really high level and if
you're a team like Indiana Utah Oklahoma
City San Antonio a place that doesn't
have a prayer of Landing a player the
caliber of Victor webayama and free in
free agency you will stomach three
months of bad basketball and public
criticism for the opportunity to get
your hand on him
have a great weekend Chris thanks for
joining us
you got it Dan that's Chris Mannix great
NBA writer for Sports Illustrated senior
writer we'll take a break uh by the way
DraftKings take advantage of the NBA
tip-off hotline presented by DraftKings
Sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the NBA promo code Patrick
make any five dollar bet this week at
200 if your team wins